Tupac when he passed away I was so
curious I said what happened to this guy
who was behind it you know the whole
thing with the fight you know he's at
your fight he's gonna get to the fight I
think you guys were supposed to spend
spend some time together and then I
interviewed Greg kating and if you know
who Greg kating is Greg kating are you
familiar with great kading no Greg
kating if you can pull up his Wikipedia
great kading
is the guy that
um he's the guy that was doing the
investigation On Tupac I remember this
okay so they had a little um television
show about this yes you're right
absolutely and he was known as the
multi-law enforcement task force that
investigated the murders of rap stars
Tupac and big edesta Wikipedia story
about him right so I said so what was
really behind this so in the video when
I interview him you know how somebody's
trying to arrest him like if you've seen
a movie American Gangster and they got
these pictures is this the guy at the
top is this the guy so I have 50
different pictures with magnets and he's
putting these things up on if you go to
the video you'll see how I set it up
with great kidding by David and I said
who is really the guy behind it he says
well we first thought it was this then
we first thought I was that and we first
thought it was this and we everything's
gone then at the end the conclusion
after multiple conversations with him
and different people it came down to
Biggie and to me there's there's so many
that right there if you can just zoom in
that's the way we had it so we're kind
of going back and forth to see who was
behind the guys that killed Biggie Tupac
easy I'm A hip-hop guy I grew up to all
this stuff with NWA this is my like you
know Straight Out of Compton was a movie
I watched God knows how many times
because I listened to all of that stuff
I'm an L.A kid so why is it that so many
people in music and Hollywood
fear this guy did he as if he's
Untouchable and even the oh sugar daddy
did it did he not sure he said biggie
but you meant I'm sorry I meant to say
Diddy not not biggie if you punch in on
the picture here you see you see Diddy
you see Suge Knight uh and then a lot of
their cohorts down there but Tupac and
Biggie at the top as you were passing
yeah so so what is it I mean everybody
is in there so what is it with Diddy
that so many T.I called them out 50 Cent
said one time on uh uh Charlemagne God's
podcast you know breakfast he says he
says one time did he said hey let me go
buy you some clothes let me take you
shopping he's like well you won't take
me shopping what are you talking about
so T.I called him out 50 called him out
but some people are afraid
what do you what what do you know about
because some people are talking about
there's Diddy involvement with Jamie and
something happened because he was
calling him out for some of the parties
he was putting up is there anything you
have opinions on Diddy have you had any
experiences with Diddy
no I'm just unknown for a long time got
it and with you he was chill he was good
he was awesome guy yeah
um I knew him before he was um Diddy
and them for a long time when I when I
first became champ I knew him I remember
him he used to have crates when he's had
my After parties and stuff also when
they were throwing parties
I remember this is when he was the CEO
founder of bad boy well I don't think
he's a bad boy yet no he wrote him Damon
Dash and all those guys they weren't
they weren't on yet
I was I was like the First Street guy
that really got on you know I'm talking
about a guy doing crime in the streets
that became a television guy and
everyone knew it was a celebrity had
fancy cars that was the first this is
all in Brooklyn I'm the first of all of
our generation of that kind of that
cruise you know the stuff Street houses
that really blew up like that you guys
all knew each other yeah it's the same
era listen um
this young lady that worked for my
company and she started saying names to
people I remember when I was 11 12 years
old and it just it baffles me that you
think you know you got away from these
people you'll never see him again you
knew them when you were at the worst of
your level I heard about them and you're
not the only one God had his hands on
these guys made them a successful too
in the sea you have to know them and see
them at this level of the game it's just
mind-boggling I mean it's really I'm
almost like proud in a way when you see
them you know what they experienced in
life and now they became respectable
citizens
I guess I'd say you know how you're in a
class of 82 or class of 90 whatever you
you're all coming up you kind of seen
who made it from your class I guess
that's how to see it when you're coming
up from the streets yeah at the same era
who else were the guys that during that
time that made it big out of all of you
listen there were um some rappers didn't
know people didn't know about that made
it real big and not just from rapping
but from writing and it's just listen um
I come from Brownsville Brooklyn very
competitive you know normally either you
succeed
um probably 60 percent of the people
don't have their high school high school
diploma it might be more but it's just a
school it's just a neighborhood for
people that normally fails just a
feeling if you don't have sports you're
not a lawyer or whatever yes you're not
going to make it you're not going to do
well you know it's very competitive very
Dog Eat Dog people who are your friends
at one time next thing you know they
turned on you come over the house I need
to do something for me man or they go
over your house and they kill you and
Rob your house for your drugs and stuff
these are the people you lived in the
sandbox with
when the drug game yeah when the drug
game nodding over here when the drug
game started in the early 80s you know
when I started the people that you were
robbing what you're friends with and
everything next thing you know you got
different gangs in your shoes all these
games we all grew up together all the
people in his gang all the people in the
gang over here some of them are related
and now they're killing it killing each
other we're all friends we grew up
together Mr Robin still together go to
the shopping together with the robin
money smoke out weed drinking together
when we were kids and next thing you
know I went over to my house after I'm
doing good in this box and stuff wasn't
Champion but almost I was making money
so somebody gets shot to go to the
hospital to see him and then somebody
else got killed so I go to the funeral
to see him but the guy went to the
hospital if the guy that killed my
friend I'm going to the funeral for
I'm crying but my friend is in this
hospital he's shot and let's say no I'm
going to my friend's funeral but he shot
my friend
it's crazy right it's really crazy yeah
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]